または何か異論とかあったら
言ってみてください  はい
えっと しばらく前に しばらく前だったと思うんですけども
長老がお書きになった文書が
この因果法則ということを言われて書いたのは知ったと思うんですけども
正しい行為と 正しい条件が揃えば正しい結果が生じると
というような文書をお書きになったと思うんですけれども
そこでその正しい行為と結果というのは
因果法則というということである程度わかるんですけども
その正しい条件というのは
どういうふうに考えたらいいんでしょうか
それはその縁ということで理解してよろしいでしょうか
うん まあ条件というのは縁のことですよ
そうしますと その条件が変わると結果も変わるということなんでしょうか
条件が変わると結果が出なくなっちゃうんですね
やっぱり条件も揃わないとね
まあ条件と縁だから それちょこっと理解した方がいいんで
例えばあの種があっただけでは芽が出て出ませんし
これ土に植えなくちゃいけないんですね
土に植えただけでも芽が出ませんね
水が必要なんですね それだけでも足りませんね
やっぱり芽が出たら光も必要でしょうしね
それ全て原因なんですね
水と種と土と光 しかし
水が種に付いてなければ
水があっても意味がないんです
例えば土に水をあげたんだけど
土から水が種に漏れていかない場合は
だから水と種が接触していることが条件で
水が原因で 種も原因で接触するっていうことは縁で
それで光は必要ですけど
光はどんな時当たるべきかということもまたあるんですね
さっきのお話の中で自分の期待と うん？ 自分の期待していることとその因果法則が頭一致したら
その まあいい時があるけど
それは全くありえない
ほとんどありえないと
いつも因果法則の方が完全に優先されると
おっしゃって  だから我々に期待する結果があれば
結果っていうのは自分勝手に起こるものじゃなくて
因果法則だから こんな結果を出すための因果法則は何なのかと学んで
その条件を揃ってあげれば自動的に結果が出るんです
うん それを それを教えていただきたいんです
何を  いや  だからそれは希望次第でしょうね
希望次第でしょうね  ですから
望む結果を得るために
どうやって原因と条件を揃えたらいいのかという
その具体的な方法が  だったら具体的な望んでいることを言ってください
人間には限りない望みあるでしょ
あります それは欲はありますけど
だからそれぞれの因果法則が違いますよ
例えば金持ちになりたいという望みがある
それだったら金持ちになるための因果法則は違うでしょうし
例えば悟りたいという望みがある
悟りたい望みと金持ちになりたい望みっていうのはもう違うでしょうね
だから因果法則もそれなりに変わるんです
例えば頭がいい人間になりたいと思う
金持ちになりたいと思う
健康的になりたいと思う
悟ってやりたいと思うとかね
全部望みでしょ それぞれの望みに対する因果法則は同じものじゃないんです
だから 望みごとに因果法則を発見しなくてはいけないんです
じゃあ具体的に あの 悟りたいと思う
それならどういう その原因
行為と条件を揃えたらいいですか？ 悟りたい人にとっては瞑想することでしょうね
欲を刺激させないことでしょ
まだまだ悟ってないんだから
欲がありますね 煩悩がありますね
煩悩はなくすことは悟りでしょう
だったら第一条件は煩悩を刺激させないこと
だから戒律あるんです
そういう煩悩が刺激しないさせてないんだから
気は出してないんだけど
煩悩はあるんです それを修行で一つ一つ叩き込んでなくしちゃうんです
例えば なんで酒飲みながら瞑想してはいけないと言ってるんですか？酒飲んじゃうと
欲やら怒りやら無知やら
ものすごい牙出して興奮して上がるでしょうに
強烈になるでしょうね
これやりながらいくら瞑想してもしてもそのままなんです
煩悩が だからまず戒律で煩悩が刺激させないことをする
例えば瞑想で怒りがなくなりますけど
瞑想で怒りをなくす前に怒りが発生しない環境でいるんです
だから慈悲の瞑想をするんです
慈悲の瞑想しちゃうと怒りまだあるんですよ
あるんだけど 芽が起きてこないんですね
それでヴィパッサナー瞑想で怒りの種が消えてしまうんです
そういうことで 戒律と瞑想で悟れるんです
戒律というのはすごいありますよね
いい椅子しかないんだけど
五戒で  うん  五戒でよろしい
五戒でいいんです  理解力が悪い
それは気にしないでください
じゃあさっきの認識のお話だったんですけれども
では催眠術でその人が石のように硬くなれてたり
硬くなっちゃったりとか
あとこう医療でイメージトレーニングで
何かいろんな体のことをいいイメージで直していくっていうのも
やっぱり認識と関わってるんですか？ うん
だから可能です 正しい
例えば病気があっても
正しい認識によって自分が健康だということで
もう教えてあげれば肉体でね
健康になるんです あるいは病気になって
この病気をお医者さんに治療してもらわなきゃ治りませんと決めたら
もうアウト 必ずお医者さんの治療が必要になっちゃうんです
これはなんとかなりますからと
明確な認識だったらね
不安があったらダメで
不安っていうのは もしかするとなんとかならないかもということだからね
そうするとそうなるんです
認識次第ですよ だから心で自由自在に物質の管理できます
はい 先ほど先生がこう包丁でとんかちの代わりに叩いてた時は
包丁で使っているよりも
やっぱりとんかちと思った方がもっとまた物質が硬くなっているんですか？ そこはなんでもないんですけど
[笑い]だから包丁ってそんな重いものじゃないでしょうしね
あんな硬い石のように硬いあれを
ふるさとはやっぱり割れましたよ
一箇所にぶん殴ってやるぞと
その時私の頭にあったイメージが
あの あの普通の石あるでしょう
でっかい黒い石が それで自分の国でも石でこの壁いろいろ作ったりすると
石はとんかちで割るんですよ
大工さんが 見事に割るんですね
もう普通 木とかだったらノコギリで切って測って
でしょ？石はそうじゃなくて
でっかい石がトンカチで見て
もういろいろところ見て
4回ぐらいガンガンってやっちゃうと綺麗に割れる
割ったらそれ持ってちゃんと壁綺麗にまっすぐに作る男を見ていたんですから
ずっと 私は思ったら不思議に適当に割れるもんだなと
こんな硬い石がと そのイメージが出てきたんですね
だからそれやっちゃうとちゃんと割れちゃったんです
それで一個だけ適当な大きさで
もう個ぐらい個ぐらいに割れましたけど
一個だけ適当なけど 他はまたまたでっかいんですけど
でもあいつ一個だけあげればいいんだから
残りはそのままにしちゃって
それで全部同じ大きさに割ってやるぞっていうことでもなかったしね
先生 認識のところで物があるという話のところなんですが
物があるは実際はない
機能はある ただ 中の道具を使うとしますね
ボールペンをボールペンで字を書くとします
ボールペンはないけれど
ボールペンに託した機能は自分が必要な時間帯だけはある
だからボールペンで字を書くっていうことも
この人間の認識なんですよ
だから字を書くっていうだけの認識あればボールペンでなくてもいいんです
書くということ自体はある
この本もこれでも書けますよ
この三脚のね これで消しちゃえば消えます
書けますからね とにかく字を書かなくちゃと思ったら
まあそれがペンの代わりに機能するんです
これで書こうと決まったら
だから認識次第ですよ
例えばもうまあちょっと鉄の
まあこれも鉄で まあそういう
例えばこれでしまった
これでやっぱりなんか書かなきゃみたいな
書くものない じゃあこれで書いて書いてやるぞと
これ金属でしょ それでちゃんと削られて書けますよ
そう思ったら これでは書けるわけないんだそういう時は書けませんね
その場合は それ削ってくれません
気持ち次第 先に気持ち決めないと
気持ちきっちり決めて
それは必要条件によって気持ちが生まれるんだから
それもそう簡単じゃないんです
じゃあ気持ち作りなさいって言われてもそう生まれません
やっぱり条件そろえないと
因果法則は自分とより別なもので働くんです
自分ができる  例えば私は今故郷をあたれ出したでしょうに
あの子が部屋にいて 紅茶飲みたいと言ったんだが
そういうことなかったら全然私にはあの思考は出てこないんです
そのままずっとあの故郷あるだけで
私は見ようともしない
ただ ああ これはもう割って適当な大きさに切っておこうぞという気分になりません
この気持ちを作ることもできないんです
なんでこんなややこしいことを今するのかとかね
そのままで方がいいんじゃないかと
ひと塊でということになるんです
だから必然性ですかね
それできると気持ちが揃ってきます
ならば OK ですよ 我々の問題は必然性があるにも関わらず気持ちが出てこない
例えば試験が迫っていて
勉強することは必然性でしょ
あるにも関わらず勉強する気持ちにならないってことで失敗するんですよ
だから好き勝手に気持ち作ることはできません
必然性が出たら適切な気持ちを作りなさいということを言っているんです
その場その場ですか よくよく見てこないですね
必然性  必然性っていうのは簡単にわかるでしょうに
成功する人っていうのは
必然性は随分大事にするんですよ
将来性ある子はもう元気ではしゃいで遊ぶっていうことじゃなくて
勉強することに興味持っちゃうんですね
スポーツもちゃんとやる
勉強もちゃんとする それで将来は心配しなくても済みます
必然性に気づかない人々はもうすごく迷惑なんですね
スポーツやって疲れたんだから
もう宿題やりたくないとかね
そうなっちゃうんです
やりたくないと思ったら意味できない
それを周りから変えることは
まあね 変えてあげなくちゃいけないんですけどね
まあどうするもね いなきゃ
おおらか者 馬鹿者だからね
子供に言うべきなのは
勉強したくないと これっていうのはものすごいわがままやと
親不孝やと 恐ろしいんだと
あんた方はこの全人類に対して罪を犯しているんだと
みじめいいところがないんだと
極悪人だと言わなくちゃ
極悪人行為なんですよ
一人の子供では自分の勉強しないっていうことは
そいつを大人になったらいかに社会に迷惑かというと
社会の負担かというとね
これ悪行為でしょ 俺だけ良ければいいっていう話でしょ
俺だけ良ければいいんだったら
ご飯も飲ませて生活してみなさいよと
服も着ないでください
どうぞ人を救ったもんだからと
なんでシャレの服やら靴やら欲しがるんでしょうかと
その権利さえもないんだよと
あいつはもうやけにシャレでしょ
それ誰かがデザインして
誰かが手仕上げて 何回何回も苦しく苦しく作って
作って もうまた間違って
また作って また間違って
すごい苦労して作るものでしょうに
これは靴を履いて ズボンを履いて
格好いいジャンパー着て
偉そうに遊び回るっていう
これはとんでもない悪行為なんですよ
自分のセクションをやらなくちゃいけないんです
だからもう極限にわがままでとんでもない行為ですと
自分がやりたいやりたくないっていう話にならないんだと
呼吸している限り ご飯を食べている限り
自分の仕事を僕はしなくちゃいけないんです
はい だからそういう連中が大人になると
もう地球に迷惑でしょうに
だからそういうところはしっかりと教えてあげないとね
選択ないっていうことなんで
それで私は気にしません
選択はないんだよと 川に落ちたら俺は泳ぎたくないんだからと
選択ないでしょうに 泳がなくちゃあかんでしょうに
そこをわかる人がね やっぱり必然性でわかっちゃうと
まあそろそろやってしまいますし
まあまあ何だろう 淡々とうまくいきます
だから私はほとんどの若い頃は
物事は一回一回で覚えることにしたのは
別に頭初めから良かったわけじゃないんです
ノート買うお金がなかったんです
だからもうノートを紙を買うお金がなくて
で 金のないっぱいあるみんな同級生たちと一緒に勉強しなくちゃいけないし
みんなもう各ノート書いて色整理整頓して立派なファイルに入れて
もうすごいよく贅沢にやってますけど
それは大変だ これどうしようかと
ノート買うお金がないんだったら
なんで 聞いたんだ なんであんたそんなにも綺麗に番号振ったり
だって勉強 試験が出たらね
さささっと勉強できますからと
なるほど やっぱり結局試験ではね
ノート持っていけませんしね
だったら私にやるのはもう一発で覚えるしかないんだと
全部一発で覚えることにしたんです
必然性なんですよ この場でこれ覚えておかなきゃ
もうどうしようかと いろいろテキストを
サンスキリト語 パーリ語とかテキスト読むでしょうに
テキスト持ってないんだ私は
ノートのお金ない奴らにテキスト買うお金あるわけないでしょうに
授業中に暗記するんです
だから逆に誰が買ったかと
私が買ったんですからね
誰一人私より悪い子にはもう叶う人いなかったんだから
誰もあれこれを指図はできなかったし
先生たちもみんなに怒ってるのに
私に一言も言わない 言ったら先生はどんな攻撃を食らうかわかりませんから
あれはもう結構覚えてるんだから
だからそれっていうのは
あなたは特別そうなに
とんでもないんです 時々私は正直に
私よりはこいつはすごく頭がいいなとか思ったりとか
結構ありましたからね
でも試験を見てくださいということで
誰がトップになっているのかと
時々正直 あ これはこいつの方がすごい上手みたいなって
思ったりしたんですけど
やっぱりそういう人々はやっぱりその必然性に迫られたっていうことはなかったし
だからただ意識だけじゃあ一回で覚えてやると
その脳は記録してくれる
いまだにノートなし喋ってますからね
もう三世代ぐらい過ぎてますけど
勉強しててね 今六十とんでますから
同級生たちはもうみんなボロボロで
本当に昔勉強したのかっていう状態で
私は未だにピカピカ状態です
知識的には だから ただ単にその気持ちになるだけのこと
物事はどうにでもなります
[背景音楽]機械まで動きますよ
機械まで 例えば機械がちょっと故障しそうだったら
あ これは普通考えが これやっぱりもう危ない
持たないとかね そうなりません
動いてくれます ボロボロになっても
一回自分の車そういうことあったんだからね
で 田舎に行って 次の日何か用事があって
もう夜九時半あたりで田舎のお寺を出てね
まあ教えてやりましたけどね
とにかく飛ばしちゃえと
十二時あたりにでも まあお寺に行かなきゃというと
もう運転してくる若者だから
そいつら夜になっちゃうと眠くなるでしょうしね
で コロンボ街を通っても行かなくちゃいけないし
まあ警備厳しいし お寺が出た途端
車の車輪からなんかすごく嫌な音が出たんです
大将向かって運転するやつは気付いてますが
私はこれは危ないということで
ちょっとおかしい あ 大丈夫やってるともうそういうんです
ただ また八キロぐらい行ったところで
まだ戻れる ない 戻れるんですよ
田舎のお寺お寺に戻っちゃえばいいんだからね
また私はもう大丈夫だって言ったって
ちょっとこれ危ないんだよと
この音は私は嫌やと 大丈夫と言ったら
また音が聞こえなくなっちゃって
私はコロンボにちょっと近寄るところ
私はずっと寝泊まりするとお寺があるんですね
ちょうどそのお寺のところになってくると
またすごい大きい音を出し始めたんです
で それでそこから私は判断するんです
まあこのお寺に行っても夜なんですけど
ドアを叩いてもう開けてもらって
夜寝ることもできるんでしょうし
まあでも面倒くさいんだからって言って
まあまあ行こうかと そこの場所を通ったら
お寺に行くまで音は出てこなかったんです
で お寺に行って駐車して
もう で 朝 朝も調べますよと
朝は車動けません 車輪のね
ボールベアリングなんてある
あの球がグニャグニャになっているんです
だからまあ よく止まるところまで動いてくれたんだからね
あれ修理すると あんなことはどうやって来たんですかと
二日間かかったんですよ
修理にはもう全部入れ替えて
もう部品もないしね 行って調べなくちゃいかんしね
何回何回もそういう やっぱり自分の要件があって
先にこれやらなくちゃってことになってくると
環境が物質はどうにも変わるんです
うん 馬鹿だねっていうかな
まあ普通この我々にはそんな好き勝手な大胆なことは思えない
ですから まあその時点では弱いんですけどね
すいません あの認識の時間があれなんですけど
認識のお話なんですけども
あのキリスト教徒がクリスチャンサイエンスということで
その成功法則だとか成功哲学だとかっていうことをあの言ってて
まあ結構昔からその手の本が売れてる
売れてまして そのまあ何冊か読んだことがあるんですけども
要するにその何か うーん
本当に何か自分がその願えば
それは必ず確実に成功するとか実現するというようなことを謳って書いてあるんですけども
それってどうもやっぱり信じられない部分です
買ったんですけども その今長老がお話しになったその認識の話と
キリスト教徒たちの言っている
そのまあ真剣に願えば何でも叶うんだっていうのと
その違いというか そういうところはどういうところが違うんでしょう
真剣に願えば完全に外れますけど
願うだけじゃなくて因果法則を起動させないと
世界は自分好き勝手に回るんじゃないんだからね
だから因果法則を起動させなくちゃいけないんです
で 私が今言ったことはもうちょこっと次元が高いんですけどね
それはもう皆挑戦しない方がいいと思いますけど
私がやっていることなんか結構とんでもないことやっていますけどね
で 普通はまあ希望があって
その希望にはこれなりの条件が必要だっていうことがあって
そこは起動させないとね
まあ仏教と違うところは
あくまでも自分でやるというセクションが欠かせません
自分のパート 人間としての
自分が何かやらなくちゃいけないんです
これはプリサカーラという単語がありますけど
人の努力 この生命が行うべき努力セクションになります
なぜならば 希望がその生命のものでしょ
ある生命が希望が持っていて
希望だけではでダメです
じゃあその希望を叶うためにあなたがどんな役割を果たすのか
自分の役割があるんです
それはもう必ずあります
自分の役割と分担が それを知らないと
その 例えばその ちょっと大きい話ですけど
一つの人類の中のその中での
その自分のその役割みたいなってことなんでしょうか
いやいや その希望に適した役割分担なんで
自分の希望でよろしいんですか？ うん
ありがとうございました
うん  すいません 一つ  はい
先ほどのあの国のエピソード
ん？ 国のエピソード  はいはい
阿羅漢になられた 以前も思い出されたんですけども
長老の本かなんかに あのお釈迦様の弟子の中で一人阿羅漢になられた方がおられて
その人を試そうと思って後ろから殴った
殴ったけれども その何の怒らず歩いていると
うん  その話をちょっと思い出されたんですが
うん  そこでの あれでは
殴られた その阿羅漢になった
その皇帝はお弟子さんは痛みというものは感じたと
うん 感じたみたいですね
サーリプッタ尊者なんですけどね
その話と今のエピソードの話で
先ほど言われたハスの花でした
うん  水滴が落ちると 水滴が落ちるというのは
要するに人間ですから
あの怒りであろうが そのその甘さであろうが
物理的なその力の加われば
何らかのその因果法則に従っても
まあ反応はあるわけでしょうけども
うん  それをそのまま捉われずに流してしまうというか
通り抜けてしまうと  うん
そういう点で そういうことをどう意味しているのか
痛みなら痛みとあって
それでそこで終わってしまう
それ以上は執着しないんですか？そういう人ではないのですか？ うーん
まあ痛みといっても実際
客観的に観察してみるしか方法ないんですけどね
説明ではちょっと難しいんですね
今日お聞きいただいたゲームの中で
あ という言語やパパというか
あ というのがありますが
我々がよく使うあの言葉は執着と同じ意味ですか？ パワーですか？パワーはもう悪ということですから
まあ執着っていうのは別物ですね
執着というのはよく日本語で言いますが
言語とは何となるか  ウパダラですね
うん いわゆる自分を割り込んで認識する場合は執着なんですね
私が痛いと言えば執着であって
痛みがあるんだなとかいうのは
まあ執着がない理解なんですね
しかし それ認識だからごまかしできないんですよ
自分がいるという前提で
これは痛みですと言ったっても
本当は本人にとっては痛いということでしょうしね
ごまかしはできないんですけど
だから私は言ったのは
ただ自分でこの自分が抜きにして痛みを感じるということができれば
あの あ なるほど 随分違うなと
だから私も 1時間ぐらいの時間があって
自分をもう体は体にして客観的に感じてみたんですね
面白かったんですけどね
一般的に言えばものすごい超痛いんですけど
でもだからといって何のこともなく
もういろいろくだらんことを言いながら
もうずっといたんですね
それで私は頭の中でいろいろ形容詞を考えなくちゃいけないんだ
だから引っ張ってきて今痛いんです
それはかなり痛いです
かなり痛いんだってって言うんで
彼女さんが それまあそれ相当相当相当痛いんだけど
そういうのをね あの痛みは色々形容しながら
もういろいろ言っていたんですけど
逆にこの喋ることは 私にとってはこの自分の認識システムがもう入れ替えたり入れ替えしなくちゃいかんだから
これちょっとややこしくてね
まああまり喋りたくなかったんですけど
喋らないで見ていたならばもっと面白かったと思いますね
それで後の話になったら
その痛みの質を考えたら
あの病気の時にあった同じ痛みなんですね
これ切ってる痛みだから別な痛みになるはずでしょ？切ったり張ったり引っ張ったりしていることだから
普通の痛みであるはずなんですけど
ある意味あの私に合った病気の時が出てくる同じ痛みはもう 1万倍もうじゃなくてもう何百倍もなって感じるだけで
あ やっぱりこれはやられているんだと
あ これはやられているんだ
普通もう切ったり張ったりする時の痛みだったらケガと同じだからね
違うな この痛みはと だからこの客観的に見るという場合の見方と認識とね
自分入って認識するという 2つありますよ
だからそれごまかしできない
自我がある限り やっぱり痛いという認識なんで
口で痛みと言っても痛いという気持ちなんですね
自我を伴わなくて認識するということは執着を捨てる
うん？ 自我 自我意識を伴わなくて何かを認識するとというのは
よく伺う執着を捨てろということ
はい だからその場合は執着は機能してないんですね
だからウパーダナ 執着あると自分のどうしようああしようという気持ちも入ってますね
だから自我が入ってない場合は
痛みであってどうしようもないんですね
その場合は だからどうしようああしようこうしようという感じが出てくるのは執着がある時なんです
だからサーリプッタ尊者は殴られても
まあどうしよう ああしよう何ともなく
まあなんかちょっと痛みが
それで終わっちゃったんですね
うん では 時間がなくなりますので
ここで終わります どうもありがとうございます